how's it going everybody gets warned
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about Marvel and
all things relating to the MCU now for
the past few months there's been a lot
of talk about Robert Downey jr. possibly
coming back to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe of course fans are super
excited about it but despite many
different reports from many different
media sources it is not yet confirmed
however last night it seems like we may
have gotten a little bit of a hint from
Robert Downey jr. himself that
eventually he could make his way back to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe Robert
Downey jr. comments along with something
that Joe Russo said last night in a live
stream he did on Instagram lead us to
believe that we may actually know how
and when iron man could return to the
MCU and I'll break down everything you
need to know in this video if you're new
be sure to subscribe to stay up to date
on all things relating to the MCU and
next week I'll be starting weekly
giveaways so to start off about a month
ago there was a report that came out
about Robert Downey jr. possibly
returning to the MCU under two
conditions a lot of various media
outlets were reporting this news and if
you didn't hear about it I'll briefly
explain the first condition was of
course money you can get Iron Man back
for the right price however a recent
rumor suggests that Robert Downey jr. is
willing to accept way less than his
normal pay and this makes sense if you
consider the fact that it's been
revealed that Robert Downey jr. made 75
million dollars for Avengers end game
alone and that is according to Forbes so
he's not exactly hurting for money but
the second condition is that he be in a
project with Tom Holland this makes
perfect sense Robert Downey jr. and Tom
Holland got very close to one another
while filming the first spider-man
homecoming movie and of course the
Avengers films as well and recently they
were both in doolittle together so
according to some reports about a month
ago these were the two conditions for
Robert Downey jr. returned to the MCU
now last night the Russo brothers did a
live stream and they were talking about
Avengers endgame and if they could come
back
many fans want the Russo brothers to
come back and direct more Marvel movies
but the Russo brothers have said that
they're taking a break for a while
however on the live stream Joe Russo
said we do have a lot of fun working on
MCU films together maybe we'll have to
do it again someday
and after that comment Robert Downey jr.
said the
we'll move us towards what they want now
this seems to be a hint that we just may
see Ironman back in the MCU at some
point because everybody right now is
pushing for Robert Downey jr. to return
and of course the Russo brothers
not to mention all of the reports
recently that state Robert Downey jr.
has been talking with Marvel Studios and
there is a connection between the Russo
brothers return and Robert Downey jr.
--zz return the Russo brothers have
stated a few times now that they would
come back to direct a Avengers Secret
Wars film
now Secret Wars is essentially a bunch
of different versions of a bunch of
different heroes from different
universes colliding and I've said it
before and I'll say it again this would
be the perfect opportunity for Robert
Downey jr. to return it would be very
brief and it wouldn't eliminate his
death because the Tony Stark that we
would be seen would be from a different
universe and everything seems to point
towards Avengers secret Wars about a
world being the next Avengers endgame
type of event especially since the one
division series coming to Disney Plus
and Doctor Strange and the multiverse of
madness are going to blow open the
multiverse and shows like Loki are going
to explore alternate timelines as well
and not to mention we can assume Tom
Hollands spider-man is going to be in
the next big Avengers film as well so
that would mean his conditions would be
met and Iron Man could return now
unfortunately this movie would not
happen for several several years in fact
it most likely won't happened until
probably about ten years from now but
that is a good thing right now Marvel
needs to move past Iron Man he died in
Avengers in game and we're moving on to
a new phase yes we miss him but we have
to move on and we have to build new
teams we have to build an Avengers team
an x-men team and the Fantastic Four
have to come into play as well and then
once they have all of their big films
separately they all come together in one
huge crossover event like infinity war
and end game so the Infinity Saga took
ten years to build up to infinity war
and endgame so this next hour will most
likely take ten years as well so if
Robert Downey jr. does eventually return
it seems like we're going to have to
wait quite a while but we could see him
and it sounds like he is definitely open
to it and if all of these reports are
accurate Robert Downey jr. is already
talking with Marvel Studios about it but
let me know what you think let me know
what you think about what the wrister
brothers said and
what Robert Downey jr. 'he's response
was and would you like to see in return
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below and don't forget to
subscribe with notifications turned on
so you can stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU for live updates you
can follow me on Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof